what up space fam golson here from anime
opera back at it again to discuss the
latest one piece
chapter and this was crazy how many rare
devil fruit reveals we got at once
or is clearly going all out leading up
to the 1000th
chapter of one piece so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing one piece reviews on this channel
and want to keep them coming then the
best thing you could do is smash that
like button and share this video with
your nakama if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos that's the way it works on
youtube so if you haven't make
this the day you subscribe and while you
wait for the next chapter to drop feel
free to check out my growing one piece
playlist where i got videos about the
supernova the warlords
the yonko and their powers the yonko's
backstories and much
much more link in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and
all this chapter is called ancient zones
and the title could not be more accurate
and at the same time
it sort of underplays the significance
of what's gonna happen not only do we
see some ancient zones
as we've been seeing with ulti page one
and drake but we also get to see the
ancient zone powers of the other three
toby ropo and we get all six of them
flaunting their transformations
it is absolutely epic but i shouldn't
get too out of myself this chapter
starts where we left off with kaido's
moving castle
kaido used his dragon powers to make the
entire island of onigashima float
keep in mind people call kaido the
strongest creature in the world
and people still make comments like who
would have thought
lord kaido could do something as
outrageous as this end quote so even
though he's already viewed as being at
the pinnacle
of power he still continues to surprise
and amaze people beyond that
we get people reacting to marco the
phoenix and wondering whose side he's on
by the way how cool is it that i could
talk about marco for the last several
chapters absolutely love having this
legend here we get a great moment where
marco seemingly sets chopper on fire
chopper is running away crying and zorro
and brook are immediately upset that
someone is attacking their teammate
understandably so it does not look good
this moment leads to confusion
on whose side marco is zorro and brooke
attack him
and i love how protective they get over
chopper but marco just flies up with his
wings and asks chopper if the flames are
hot
it is only then that chopper stops
freaking out
realizing that the fire doesn't burn the
flames are just helping with the virus
they are at the right temperature to
suppress it and many thought that
marco's flames would help with the virus
and they did
but i liked that they didn't just solve
the problem altogether
after all dr chopper needs his time to
shine since he's the one that's been set
up as the one who will create
the antibodies so the way things stand
marco held by time and chopper will fix
the problem
some nice teamwork there with help from
mink tribe dr miyagi and nurse tristan
chopper plans to go into the tower to
focus on the cure marco sees a bunch of
ice demons and decides to handle them
all at once spreading his passive flames
all over the place and we get the same
beautiful moment where like chopper
people just assume that the flames are
hot so hot until they realize that they
actually aren't instead people can feel
themselves defrosting and regain their
personalities like boss omasum as marco
points out the flames are drawing out
their
body heat but when their stamina runs
out they'll start turning into ice
demons again
queen is mad that marco is getting in
the way of his amusements and i love
seeing an angered queen
i'm ready for queen to get in a serious
fight already rather than just
messing around and not that zorro needs
more convincing that marco is on their
side now but this dude who at first
appeared like an enemy who set chopper
on fire now offers to fly them to the
roof
where luffy and jinbe have been trying
to get to the whole time to confront
kaido big mom should be there too though
so this whole situation is just like a
dynamite getting ready to blow
you know something big is coming you
just don't know how soon exactly
it seems that if things go according to
plan he'll fly zorro brook and the
beautiful robin
up to the roof while boss kyogro and his
men look after chopper we do have funny
moments laced in here with marco
mentioning that they don't want to stay
here and fight small fry aka
extras which is what we like to hear
since it means more significant battles
will take place soon and also hyogero
calls brook
mr skeleton and chopper mr raccoon which
was pretty hilarious not gonna lie
there's a moment i absolutely love where
apu gets up like he's gonna actually do
something
he goes to attack chopper but in just a
few panels he's dealt with when drake
catches him in his dino mouth
the first flying six member albeit a
former member
has transformed into his ancient zone
allosaurus form
and in this chapter all the other flying
sex members aka the tobiropo
are gonna follow suit too now it seems
super clear to anyone
what side drake is on and drake tells
zoro to leave this floor to him zorro is
now convinced too
and laughs saying that drake is smarter
than he looks
because he's aligned himself with the
winning side gotta love kakizoro
who says such things when they still
have two yonko and many more powerful
opponents to take out
we then jump to jinbe and luffy
wondering about sanji and i absolutely
love this moment
they don't think that a woman got him
but that he sensed the presence of a
strong enemy
and decided to stop them on the third
floor and luffy says and i quote i see
seems like my observation hockey still
needs work and quote
that just might be the funniest moment
of the chapter for me
then jinbei says that it looks like one
of them will have to stay on this floor
suggesting that there are very powerful
opponents here
we see feline shadows suggesting it's
cat batman
of the flying six himself but for now we
move on to frankie i'm actually worried
about frankie since he has to go up
against sasaki
the guy that was suggested to be one of
the strongest of the flying six and a
potential all-star candidate
now we finally see sasuke's form which
is that of a triceratops and when i saw
this i had a nostalgic moment because it
reminded me of the land before time
but this triceratops is less friendly
and more
deadly again making me question why
denjiro left him alive so he could join
the battle later
sasaki tells frankie to give up and says
that dinosaurs are the strongest
creatures to have ever lived
and that statement makes me wanna say
that dragon should be the strongest
creatures but then maybe he's not
counting mythical beings like dragons
and phoenixes
or maybe dragons count as dinosaurs
since every time we're introduced to a
dinosaur they're classified as having a
dragon dragon fruit with a specific
dinosaur model
could just be a translation thing from
japanese to english but it still made me
stop and think
nevertheless these ancient zones are
definitely top tier
zone users in the meantime sanji is
trying to run from the ladies
and man i love sanji they don't let him
run away and we see black maria
transform into a giant spider it is an
ancient zone spider spider fruit
model and i'm gonna butcher this rosa
miguel
gravogeli i have no idea if i said that
right i'd be shocked if i did but i did
look it up
and it turns out like black maria this
spider did not go
searching for prey but waited in its
burrow for its prey
to come along and then it would trap it
kind of how sanji just walked into this
trap as well even upside down with a
spider bottom half
black maria's upper half still looks
absolutely gorgeous but i think this
scene is supposed to be scary
all of the demonic woman closing in on
the trapped sanji however for sanji he's
thinking that he has to escape
but and here's the kicker everywhere he
looks there are women
and he wonders if he is in heaven even
the woman trapping him have to wonder if
he's nuts
since that's where his mind goes in this
otherwise nightmare situation
they're even thinking yo this dude
should be freaked out right now i love
how all of the freaky looking animal
modifications have no sway on sanji
at all he can only focus on how great
this situation is because he's
surrounded by so many women and i take
my previous comment back
this is the funniest moment of the
chapter for me
seeing sanji's face like this it was
gold but it's noteworthy that
both of my most funny moments in this
chapter revolved around my boy sanji
then as expected we figured out that it
was who's who
who faced luffy and jimbei and just by
the matchups here and the fact that he
was the last to be
revealed it would seem that this cat
batman is the strongest of the six
but it's too early to say so
conclusively who's who
ended up having the very cool power of a
saber-toothed tiger i gotta admit
i didn't think it would be this cool of
a cat power but sabertooth tiger is
pretty dope
luffy has gotten away leaving jinbei to
deal with the felines
who's who calls jimbei a former warlord
but jinbei prefers to be known as the
helmsman of the straw hat pirates and
that's one of those moments that you
could easily skip past
but it's actually really cool when you
think about it i love how
proud the straw hats are to be a part of
this crew
we also have an interesting moment where
it turns out that jinbei
and who's who crossed paths before but
who's who refuses to show his face
so that jinbei could jog his memory it
may be random
but it seems like that will come up
again perhaps when jinbe takes off his
mask
we then get the complete transformation
of ulti
and page 1 before jumping to the inside
of the dome
storeroom where momo and yamato are
talking
there's a statue of a golden dragon that
used to be at the entrance of the island
but was abandoned here
after a friend of hers broke it and that
friend clearly seems to be ace
and yamato says he came a few years ago
to kill kaido too and that is the end of
this chapter
i like the whole luffy carrying out what
a started thing going on i love the
yonko vs warlords thing going on
and in general we got so many epic stuff
that's about to blow up
my prediction although it's vague af is
that chapter 1000 will be the one where
most of the setting up turns into epic
fights
1000 will be the dynamite explosion
where all hell breaks loose
nevertheless these lead-up chapters have
been great in their own right
and this one was not only hilarious but
we got so many reveals about these epic
ancient zone powers you gotta love it as
always let me know your thoughts on this
chapter below
and what you expect to see happening
next if you did enjoy this review and
want to keep the one piece reviews
coming then the best thing you could do
is smash that like button and share this
video with your nakama
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos make
this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist
where i got videos about the supernova
the warlords the yonko and much
much more linked to those are in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself and
the most donated
champion of the world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata the world acquire respect liam
thompson pattay heffa ruthean
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinel baked buddhist
tungsten tarkis and denki kaminari and
our pro hero to your patrons the one and
only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazowski
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font alicia actor bonnie parks
you know comey and water the red-haired
raven florian joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz and anthony schreiber
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
animeopro and becoming a patron today
for as long as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
legendary people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you could also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way
if you prefer whichever way you support
us you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
so
you